[Aplausos]
voy a empezar diciendo algo que no tenía
planeado decir
saben yo creo que hay Muy pocas personas
en Europa
o en los Estados Unidos el continente
norteamericano que piense que este
hombre
se levantaría y pediría o iría ayudar a
Ucrania
incrementa el presupuesto militar y
Japón fue Japón el que apoyo Porque
entendió que cuando alguna parte del
mundo tiene 185
mil personas soldados cruzando la
frontera que están robando la soberanía
de otra nación que eso afecta al mundo
entero quiero agradecerle nuevamente
públicamente
[Aplausos]
la primera reunión del Consejo de
Ucrania y otan y todos nuestros aliados
están de acuerdo que el futuro de
Ucrania está en la otan eso no es una
sorpresa para nadie no lo creo Espero
que no sea una sorpresa para usted señor
presidente los aliados
viven los plan de acción para Ucrania y
para crear una vía la membresía de la
otan mientras que Ucrania continúa
progresando en los formularios
necesarios pero no estamos esperando a
que ese proceso culmine para hacer los
compromisos a largo plazo que estamos
haciendo con la seguridad de Ucrania
polo de Miri y yo
no voy a ser tan familiar el señor
selensky y yo hablamos de los tipos de
garantías que podemos dar en el Mientras
tanto mientras yo estuve en Ucrania en
otros lugares también entonces el día de
hoy
los compromisos a largo plazo que
estamos haciendo está respaldados por la
noción de que mientras tanto vamos a
proporcionar seguridad a Ucrania
para contra cualquier agresión que pueda
ocurrir hoy los miembros del g7 están
lanzando un apoyo una clase de apoyo
conjunta para Ucrania y garantizamos que
esto pollo va a durar a futuro esto
inicia el proceso por el cual cada una
de nuestras naciones y cualquier otra
nación que desee participar va a
negociar compromisos de Ciber
bilaterales a largo plazo con Ucrania
vamos a ayudarle a Ucrania desarrollar
una defensa fuerte y capaz en tierra
aire y mar que va a haber una fuerza de
estabilidad en la región para disolver
cualquier y todas las amenazas quiero
agradecerle a mis colegas líderes del g7
el presidente de su trabajo para que
esto suceda me parece una declaración
contundente
del compromiso con Ucrania mientras
defiendas y libertad del día de hoy y
mientras reconstruye Su futuro y vamos a
estar ahí por el tiempo que sea
necesario Y de nuevo le agradezco a
todos mis colegas por su apoyo con esto
[Aplausos]
Muchas gracias señor presidente señor
presidente biden pero en nuestro
cuchillo
el presidente macron Primer Ministro
Line es un gran honor estar aquí el
resultado de la Cumbre de
la otan en vilna es muy significativa
para Ucrania y les agradezco a todos los
líderes en la conferencia de la otan por
el apoyo sin presidentes y muy práctico
es la clave para las relaciones de apoyo
a ucraneo el día del equipo de seguridad
garantiza para Ucrania en su camino
hacia la otan un paquete importante de
garantías de seguridad hoy en día
estamos coordinando con la conferencia
del g7 el marco para las garantías de
seguridad que se va a extender aún más
con nuestros socios claves
acuerdos bilaterales y multilaterales y
las delegación ucraniana está trayendo
una victoria en seguridad significativa
para Ucrania para nuestro país para
nuestra gente para nuestros niños y nos
Abre una unas oportunidades totalmente
nuevas y creo que ustedes lo hicieron
posible Muchas gracias estimados colegas
gracias a ustedes gracias
gracias de nuevo Muchas gracias
[Aplausos]